[Musique]
deux hommes sont morts la même page de
journal a eu ni leur nom en enrôlant le
colonel fabien paris a fait à fabien des
obsèques grandioses devant son cercueil
exposé sur les marches de l'hôtel de
ville berceau des libertés parisienne
contre ceux de deux fidèles compagnons
d'armes une foule immense a défilé
au même moment de l'église de clamecy
encore pèse d'un team accompagné romain
rolland au cimetière provincial ou d'or
de ses parents
[Musique]
en enrôlant était un vieillard il meurt
à 79 ans sur cette butte de vézelay dont
la basilique entendu saint-bernard
prêcher la seconde croisade
dans cette maison il passe à ces cinq
dernières années entre sa table de
travail
et son lit de malade à écrire cette vie
de pki dont les derniers mots battre
comme un seul coeur résume toute son
oeuvre cette oeuvre basée sur l'amour
des hommes et l'amour de cette liberté
pour laquelle il lutta toute sa vie
va bien avait 26 ans sa femme
aujourd'hui déporté en allemagne son
père fusillé par les allemands formait
avec lui dans ce faubourg de paris 1
foyers d'ouvriers parmi d'autres foyers
d'ouvriers boulanger il ne savait rien
de romain rolland mais il respire elle
est ou en un relent ajouté tant de fois
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il fut à 17
ans un soldat en espagne
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'on métro
barbès in aphatie le premier allemand
tué à paris
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il crée en
france les premiers maquis de la liberté
c'est pour cela peut-être qui fut jeté
dans un cachot doubs par un souterrain
il s'évada vie jour après
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il a pris
sa part dans la libération de paris en
faisant flotter les pros couleurs sur le
luxembourg
nommé colonel c'est pour cela peut-être
qu'elle partait pour le front de
lorraine et que dans un coup de main il
y des morts
et
ainsi la tombe de fabien l'homme
d'action rejoint réponse de l'homme de
pensée qui toute sa longue vie lança aux
hommes son message de raison et de fois
dans le monde entier son message à 17
jours des consciences c'est à cause de
ce que l'on a écrit l'autre a agi c'est
parce que l'air de la maison de renards
volants est passé sur la maison de
famille un cas tous deux offrent les
mots du panthéon ou grands hommes la
patrie reconnaissante
[Musique]